Olá, boa noite.
Boa noite.
Nós estamos entrevistando esta semana os candidatos à presidência da República nas eleições
2026.
Foram convidados os seis candidatos mais bem colocados na pesquisa Quest de 14 de agosto.
A ordem das entrevistas foi decidida num sorteio com a presença de representantes das campanhas.
Hoje nós recebemos aqui no estúdio o candidato Flávio Bolsonaro do PL.
Amanhã, nosso convidado é Augusto Cury do Avante.
Nós já entrevistamos Romeu Zema do Novo, Ronaldo Caiado do PSD, Renan Santos do Missão e Luiz
Inácio Lula da Silva do PT.
Cada entrevista tem 40 minutos de duração com dois blocos e as considerações finais
dos candidatos.
Então, vamos começar relembrando a trajetória política de Flávio Bolsonaro.
Flávio Nantes Bolsonaro tem 45 anos.
Nasceu em Resende, no Rio de Janeiro.
É advogado e empresário.
Entrou na política no início dos anos 2000 por influência do pai, Jair Bolsonaro.
Começou no Partido Progressista Brasileiro.
Em 2002, foi eleito o deputado mais novo da Assembleia do Rio, onde ficou por quatro
mandatos consecutivos.
Em três deles, no Partido Progressista.
Disputou a Prefeitura do Rio em 2016 pelo PSC e terminou em quarto lugar.
Dois anos depois, foi eleito senador pelo Partido Social Liberal.
Agora, disputa pela primeira vez a presidência pelo PL.
O candidato a vice é do mesmo partido.
O deputado federal por Alagoas, Alfredo Gaspar.
Candidato, boa noite.
Obrigada pela sua presença.
Boa noite, candidato.
Boa noite, Renata.
Boa noite, Trai.
Boa tarde.
Boa noite a você que está em casa e a sua família também.
O tempo da entrevista começa a ser contado a partir de agora e eu quero começar ouvindo
o senhor sobre o escândalo do Banco Master.
O candidato banqueiro Daniel Vorcaro está preso por fraudes bilionárias e ele repassou
61 milhões de reais para financiar um filme sobre seu pai, Jair Bolsonaro.
Primeiro, o senhor negou ter pedido dinheiro para o Vorcaro.
Em seguida, vieram a público mensagens de áudio mostrando que sim, o senhor pediu, cobrou
dinheiro de Vorcaro para o filme.
Em seguida, o senhor omitiu ter se encontrado com Vorcaro.
Em seguida, o senhor reconheceu que se encontrou sim com Vorcaro, foi até a casa dele, inclusive
no dia seguinte à saída dele da prisão.
Eu pergunto ao senhor, diante de todas essas contradições, como convencer o eleitor de
que o senhor não teve um relacionamento próximo com Daniel Vorcaro?
Renata, em primeiro lugar, quero prestar minha solidariedade a você pelo ocorrido aqui
no dia de ontem, na sabatina com o próprio presidente da República.
Uma descortesia com que ele cometeu da minha parte.
Obviamente, eu fiquei à vontade para fazer qualquer tipo de pergunta.
Como essa pergunta que eu acho que tem que ser esclarecida sempre, apesar de eu ter falado
várias vezes sobre isso, nunca é demais explicar, não só para vocês, mas principalmente
para quem está em casa aqui me assistindo, que não tem absolutamente nada de errado em
um filho buscar um financiamento privado para um filho do próprio pai.
E alguém que, obviamente, apesar de ser senador, não teve nenhuma contrapartida pelo fato
de eu ser senador da República para esse investidor.
Então, Renata, eu de verdade não tenho absolutamente nada de irregular nesse filme.
Eu não fui buscar dinheiro em Lei Rouanet, eu não fui buscar dinheiro em recursos públicos.
E esse foi um patrocínio, na verdade, que não tem nenhuma transferência para Flávio
Bolsonaro.
É um patrocínio para um filme privado sobre o meu pai.
Sim, também é importante esses fatos porque o senhor é um senador da República pleiteando
o cargo da presidência e recebeu valores milionários de um banqueiro que está preso
por crimes graves, incluindo fraudes bilionárias, incluindo dinheiro de aposentados, milícia
privada contra inimigos.
Por isso é de interesse público que entender não só a sua relação com ele, mas também
o detalhamento desse financiamento.
Sobre a sua relação com ele, na véspera da prisão de Vorcaro, quando as fraudes e
as investigações já eram conhecidas e noticiadas, o senhor chegou a dizer numa conversa o seguinte,
estou e estarei contigo sempre.
O que o senhor quis dizer com isso?
Bom, Renata, é importante separar o tipo de relação privada que envolve esse patrocínio
para um filme, que é o mesmo tipo de relação privada de um banqueiro que investiu também,
deu um patrocínio de 160 milhões de reais para um programa do Luciano Huck aqui da Globo.
Não tem absolutamente nada de errado, é a mesma pessoa que fez um investimento de 50 milhões
reais no Grupo Globo, na Editora Globo mais especificamente, para que fossem dadas várias
palestras, inclusive uma em Nova York, que foi do valor econômico, que é do Grupo Globo.
Então, isso aqui, Renata, o patrocínio para o Grupo Globo, o patrocínio para o filme
privado, isso aqui foi de boa fé.
Não tem nada de legal, está tudo correto, porque é completamente diferente da relação
que ele construiu junto ao atual governo.
Mas o que o senhor quis dizer com estarei sempre contigo?
Qual era a relação pessoal?
A única relação que eu tinha com ele, Renata, era sobre esse filme e mais nada.
Então, na verdade, ali o filme já estava acontecendo, eu não queria que essa obra de arte fosse
perdida, é um sonho que estava se realizando, o presidente Bolsonaro merece uma obra de arte,
uma obra-prima, como um filme, contando a história, como um herói, que é o que de fato ele é,
resistiu, inclusive, a uma facada até chegar à presidência da República, deu o seu melhor.
Então, foi ali uma forma de garantir que esse filme acontecesse.
E muito em breve, se Deus quiser, todos vão poder assistir esse grande filme sobre o Jair
Messias Bolsonaro.
Candidato, o senhor se referiu a esse patrocínio do evento do Grupo Globo?
Essas relações com anunciantes, elas são sempre pautadas pelo respeito completo às leis,
autorregulamentação também da publicidade e são registradas com absoluta transparência.
Então, é importante dizer isso aqui ao senhor, uma vez que o senhor trouxe esse assunto.
E, obviamente, como nós estamos trazendo aqui, essa relação do senhor com o banqueiro Daniel
Vorcaro é extremamente importante para o eleitor, exatamente pelo fato de que ele é investigado
pela maior fraude financeira do sistema brasileiro.
E mais detalhes são importantes também sobre o caminho desse dinheiro para o financiamento.
O assunto não é página virada porque, justamente, o senhor não apresentou o contrato com Daniel
Vorcaro.
O senhor não apresentou uma planilha detalhada com os milhões gastos no filme, como o senhor
prometeu fazer, inclusive, em maio.
O senhor não esclareceu quem são todos os investidores, quanto cada um colocou no filme.
O senhor não esclareceu quanto do dinheiro do fundo criado no exterior foi, de fato, para
o filme.
O eleitor não merece explicações mais claras sobre esse episódio, que ainda está obscuro?
Não merece e é o que eu estou fazendo aqui, Renata.
Por favor.
É uma relação privada, mais uma vez, que eu só me sinto na obrigação, inclusive,
de prestar todos os esclarecimentos, porque, obviamente, eu sou candidato à presidência
da República.
Então, mais uma vez, todo o patrocínio que foi feito no filme foi usado no filme.
Logo assim que veio à tona esse áudio e que começou-se a toda a montagem dessa conjuntura,
como se tivesse algo de errado nessa relação, que absolutamente não tem nada de errado,
eu pedi o quê?
Eu falei que era em 30 dias que a produtora apresente uma prestação de contas.
E, antes desse prazo, a prestação de contas foi feita, inclusive, na investigação que
estava acontecendo na Polícia Civil de São Paulo, por exigência minha, antes dos 30
dias.
Inclusive, eu vi na própria imprensa.
Foi publicado no site do G1.
A prestação de contas estava acontecendo.
E como se não bastasse antes de ontem.
Candidato, em relação ao site do G1, o senhor falou sobre essa prestação de contas.
O G1 trouxe os valores apresentados pela produtora do filme.
Mas o próprio G1 também disse que o perito contratado por ela não trouxe mais nenhum tipo
de detalhe em relação ao conteúdo dos valores apresentados.
Então, o perito, olha só, ele admitiu que ele não acessou o fundo americano que recebeu
o dinheiro do Vorcaro.
E a Polícia Federal considera que essa análise é fundamental exatamente para conseguir entender
a origem e o destino desse dinheiro todo, se ficou no Brasil, se foi para fora do Brasil,
ou seja, seguir o caminho de todo esse dinheiro.
O perito não apresentou nota fiscal, não apresentou comprovante de transferência bancária,
não deu nome de financiador, não explicou a origem, o destino, como eu disse, de R$ 75 milhões,
ou seja, ele não esclareceu nada em relação ao caminho do dinheiro.
Por que o senhor não apresenta o contrato?
Não é do seu interesse, da completa transparência isso?
Tralha, do completo interesse e, mais uma vez, tudo já vê à tona pela imprensa.
Há dois ou três dias, mais uma vez, uma reportagem da revista Veja, tratando não apenas da prestação
de contas, mas também da perícia.
O que a perícia conclui, Tralha?
Conclui que não tem um centavo de dinheiro público nesse filme.
É uma relação completamente privada.
E mais, essa perícia mostra também, Tralha, que o patrocínio que foi feito por ele, o
filme custou mais do que o patrocínio que ele fez.
E o contrato também veio à tona quando vazaram as conversas entre uma pessoa e o Daniel
Vorcaro.
O senhor não vai apresentar, então, o detalhamento da planilha?
Já está apresentado, já está apresentado e, inclusive, foi em razão desse vazamento.
Todos sabem hoje...
Eu citei com o senhor agora uma série de informações do perito que não trazem absoluta clareza em
relação ao que aconteceu.
Trazem, como qualquer pessoa pública tem que prestar os crescimentos.
Da minha parte aqui, o que eu vi na imprensa, mais uma vez, inclusive, para concluir essa
resposta, Tralha, é que essa perícia mostra que, além de não ter tido um centavo de dinheiro
público, o patrocínio que foi feito, o que a produtora usou para fazer esse filme, foi
mais, inclusive, do que foi esse patrocínio realizado.
Ou seja, o dinheiro, o recurso foi todo investido na produção do filme.
Candidato, quando o senhor vai tornar público o contrato que o senhor teve com o Daniel Vorcaro,
o contrato que o senhor firmou com o Daniel Vorcaro para receber esse dinheiro...
Eu não firmei contrato com ninguém.
A minha parte nesse filme foi autorizar o uso da minha imagem e captar investidores.
O contrato não cabe a mim.
O detalhamento da planilha, por exemplo.
A planilha, candidato.
Mas você está esclarecido, como tem dinheiro público, a origem do patrocínio, o Tralha,
a mesma origem do investimento do patrocínio que foi feito aqui na Globo.
Candidato, mas é dinheiro que Vorcaro.
Não é direito de cama, não é dinheiro de início.
O dinheiro que Vorcaro distribuía era fruto de fraudes bilionárias.
O senhor está pleiteando um cargo máximo da República.
O senhor precisa de toda a transparência, inclusive com negócios privados que o senhor faz,
para justamente dar ao eleitor essas informações claras sobre o caminho do dinheiro,
que negócios o senhor faz com o banqueiro e também a relação que o senhor tem com o dinheiro.
Está mais do que esclarecido.
Inclusive, eu pedia muito que houvesse a CPMI do Banco Master.
Você vai mostrar.
Eu já assinei a CPMI, eu pedi que ela acontecesse, porque tudo que eu queria que sentasse lá Augusto Lima e Daniel Vorcaro,
para perguntar qual a sua relação com o Flávio Bolsonaro.
Não ia falar nenhuma relação com o Fim.
Agora, qual a sua relação com o Lula?
Qual a sua relação com o Jacques Wagner?
Qual a sua relação com o Ricosta?
Qual a sua relação com o Galípolo?
Vorcaro, o que é que você conversou naquela reunião com o presidente Lula,
naquela reunião secreta que ele fez junto com o Galípolo, junto com o Augusto Lima,
em que foi prometido...
Olha só, espera um pouquinho, Vorcaro.
O Lula falando isso, espera um pouquinho,
porque daqui a pouco eu troco o presidente do Banco Central com o Galípolo presente nessa reunião.
O Galípolo sentado lá para ele trocar o presidente do Banco Central
para o presidente do Banco Central novo, indicado por Lula, resolver o Banco Master.
E a sua visita ao banqueiro Daniel Vorcaro, ao dono do Master?
Toda a minha relação com ele, Renata, sempre foi relativa ao filme, absolutamente.
E o senhor se compromete a tornar públicas os detalhes desse filme?
Já estão públicas.
As informações que são importantes já estão públicas.
Candidato, relembrando, só para o eleitor ter a cronologia do que aconteceu,
o senhor recebeu 61 milhões de reais por filme...
Não, não recebi, Renata, por favor.
Eu não recebi dinheiro nenhum.
Foi um patrocínio para um que fez o filme, para a produtora que fez o filme.
Exatamente.
Não fui eu...
Só para deixar bem na cara, nunca recebi.
O senhor, inclusive, pediu dinheiro a ele.
O senhor pediu dinheiro a ele.
Pediu um patrocínio.
Isso, patrocínio.
Foi um patrocínio para o filme, não foi dinheiro para a Flávia.
Deixar bem claro.
Teria pedido a Vorcaro 134 milhões de reais.
No fim de 2025, o senhor visitou Daniel Vorcaro em São Paulo.
Naquele momento, inclusive, as fraudes do Master já eram amplamente conhecidas ao público.
Vorcaro, inclusive, já tinha sido preso.
Estava com tornozeleira eletrônica.
Eu pergunto ao senhor, o senhor alegou que foi lá para dar fim à relação que o senhor tinha ao Vorcaro.
É adequado um senador da República visitar a casa de um banqueiro investigado por fraudes bilionárias no sistema financeiro, incluindo o dinheiro dos aposentados?
Olha, Renato, o que não é adequado é um presidente da República receber uma reunião secreta, um banqueiro prometendo ajudá-lo a resolver o problema do seu banco.
Então, fica a pergunta aqui, quem deve esclarecimentos é o Lula.
Ele é sócio, ele é conselheiro ou ele é só amigo do Vorcaro e do Augusto Lima?
Quem deve explicações hoje é o atual presidente da República.
Mais uma vez, uma relação privada que não teve absolutamente nenhuma contrapartida da minha parte de favorecê-lo de alguma forma,
porque, obviamente, eu sou oposição ao atual governo.
Nada que ele pudesse me pedir de ajuda para resolver um poder público, eu poderia ajudá-lo.
Então, mais uma vez, isso é um livro que está fechado, ressignificado e na prateleira para quem quiser abrir e ter acesso a hora que quiserem.
Mas o senhor não vai tornar públicas as informações ainda?
Está aberto para o público, está aberto para o público pela imprensa.
O eleitor ainda não tem essa planilha, não tem os detalhes, não tem, enfim, tudo o que nós tratamos aqui.
Eu vou seguir, então, para a gente falar agora sobre a tentativa de golpe de Estado no Brasil, candidato.
Mas só para antes de fechar esse assunto, que é importante.
Candidato, ao julgar o caso, o Supremo Tribunal Federal identificou 13 atos numa trama que começou antes das eleições de 2022
e culminou no ataque às sedes dos três poderes em 8 de janeiro de 2023.
Seu pai, o ex-presidente Jair Bolsonaro, ele foi condenado a 27 anos e 3 meses de prisão
por liderar uma organização criminosa que tentou impedir a alternância de poder depois das eleições.
E o Supremo enumerou as seguintes ações golpistas.
Campanha para desacreditar as urnas eletrônicas e a justiça eleitoral.
Pressão sobre as forças armadas.
Uso de órgãos públicos contra adversários.
Plano para assassinar o então presidente eleito, o vice e o ministro do Supremo.
E a elaboração da chamada minuta do golpe.
Diante disso, pergunto ao senhor que garantias o eleitor tem de que o seu grupo político não vai voltar a atacar a democracia se o senhor for eleito.
É muito importante a sua pergunta, para que quem está nos assistindo possa saber a grande farsa que foi armada para tirar o presidente Bolsonaro da vida pública.
Você citou algumas acusações pelas quais ele foi condenado, ele foi julgado pelos seus inimigos.
Você tem ideia?
Olha, eu vou te falar uma coisa, você nunca queira ser julgado pelos seus inimigos.
Porque você já sabe qual vai ser o resultado final antes do processo começar.
Você falou alguns crimes que foram imputados a ele.
Organização criminosa armada.
Que organização as pessoas que estavam naquele 8 de janeiro nem se conheciam?
Nunca se viram na vida?
E armada?
Não foi encontrada uma arma no 8 de janeiro, tralho?
Como é que alguém pode ser condenado, como foi o presidente Bolsonaro e centenas de outras pessoas,
por depredação de patrimônio público, se ele estava a mais de 10 mil quilômetros de distância de Brasília?
Eu, para quebrar esse copo, tenho que pegar ele na mão, tenho que tacar ele no chão.
E aí você pode me acusar de ter quebrado o copo.
Depredação de um patrimônio público, a pessoa tem que estar fisicamente no mesmo local para poder cometer.
Ele foi imputado, esse crime a ele.
É uma depredação de patrimônio público por Wi-Fi?
É o golpe da Disney, que eles estavam nos Estados Unidos?
Então, claramente, tralho, isso tudo foi uma farsa que foi armada.
Ele foi, só para fechar essa primeira pergunta sobre isso, olha quem foi que julgou ele.
Alexandre de Moraes, um inimigo declarado do presidente Bolsonaro.
Flávio Dino, outro ministro indicado pelo Lula, que tem, inclusive, processo criminal contra o Bolsonaro,
que disse que o Bolsonaro é o demônio na terra.
O outro, Zanin, indicado pelo Lula, que até ontem era advogado do Lula.
Você acha que isso foi um julgamento justo?
Candidato, e os depoimentos que embasam esse processo criminal que resultou nas condenações?
Tem vários depoimentos de generais de alta patente dentro do governo, na época do governo do seu pai.
General Mário Fernandes trabalhava no Palácio do Planalto, confirmou em interrogatório que foi o autor do plano para matar as autoridades.
A PF encontrou o arquivo no Palácio do Planalto, rastreou os celulares dos envolvidos, confirmou que esse documento foi levado até o Palácio da Alvorada,
a residência oficial do presidente da República.
O general chegou a dizer que o documento era um pensamento digitalizado, mas as investigações apontaram que o grupo só não conseguiu concluir esse plano
porque não foi possível, não conseguiu cooptar o comando do Exército.
Planejar matar autoridades não é um crime contra a democracia brasileira?
Olha, Trale, você está falando de pessoas que acusam ou que fizeram essa montagem, esse contexto mentiroso para condenar essas pessoas.
Se esse general planejou isso, a responsabilidade é dele.
Por que o depoimento do Cid, quando ele diz que nunca foi tratado de golpe dentro do governo, com o presidente Bolsonaro ou com qualquer pessoa,
por que isso foi desconsiderado? A gente está falando, outra, de um relator desse processo que foi ofendido no aeroporto lá na Itália.
E o que ele faz? Ele abre um processo contra as pessoas que supostamente constrangeram ele no aeroporto da Itália
como sendo um crime ou atentado contra a democracia porque foi o ministro supremo que foi ali constrangido em algum momento.
Então, essa segurança jurídica que eu vou trazer de volta, eu sou o único candidato que pode trazer essa segurança jurídica de volta,
sou o único candidato que pode recolocar as instituições no seu devido lugar para que o Supremo volte a cumprir a Constituição,
ou melhor dizendo, a parte do Supremo volte a cumprir a Constituição.
Porque hoje, ô César Trale, o que está acontecendo? Até fontes jornalísticas são ameaçadas, têm quebra de sigilo, sofrem busca e apreensão,
lesando um direito sagrado de todo jornalista de sigilo da sua fonte.
Porque um jornalista do Maranhão estava fazendo denúncias de uso do bem público, que era o do Flávio Dino, de forma irregular.
Candidato, vou trazer outros depoimentos importantes aqui, então.
Lembrando que afirmaram os comandantes do Exército e da Aeronáutica no governo de seu pai, Brigadeiro Batista Júnior,
disse que houve risco iminente de golpe de Estado e pressões para que militares aderissem a uma ruptura institucional.
General Freire Gomes confirmou que a minuta do golpe foi apresentada e discutida em reunião com Jair Bolsonaro.
Como é que o senhor avalia essas declarações do comandante do Exército e da Aeronáutica?
Isso não é grave?
Não, não é grave porque está partindo de uma pessoa como esse comandante da Aeronáutica aí, que hoje está pedindo voto por Lula.
Uma pessoa completamente parcial para falar sobre o presidente Bolsonaro.
Agora, tem um detalhe que é legal a gente resgatar na história, muito rapidamente, prometo.
Os crimes que são considerados aí insuscetíveis de anistia, de indulto, por exemplo,
são tráfico de drogas, tortura, crimes hediondos.
E a parte do crime que estava lá, crimes contra o Estado Democrático de Direito, na Constituição de 88,
foi retirado por um destaque.
Ou seja, estava no texto original da Constituição,
parlamentares fizeram um procedimento regimental para tirar essa parte de atentados contra o Estado Democrático de Direito,
como passíveis de indulto ou de anistia.
Sabe quem votou a favor de tirar esse destaque de lá?
Lula, Fernando Henrique Cardoso e vários outros medalhões da política brasileira?
Candidato.
Para deixar bem claro que isso é suscetível de anistia.
E eu, como presidente da República, vou fazer, vou trabalhar para que a anistia seja feita ainda na transição
e, se caso não ocorra, um indulto para as pessoas do dia de janeiro, porque vocês vão ser honrados.
Esse ponto é importante.
O fato é que o Supremo julgou, por maioria, que houve tentativa de golpe de Estado e mais quatro crimes,
pelos quais o seu pai está preso.
O senhor diz que, se eleito, vai anistiá-lo.
E o senhor, como ele, atacou as urnas eletrônicas brasileiras durante um encontro também com diplomatas estrangeiros.
O senhor disseminou informações que já tinham sido desmentidas pelo Tribunal Superior Eleitoral.
O presidente Nunes Marques precisou sair em defesa das urnas eletrônicas.
Ele declarou o seguinte, desacreditar o sistema de votação é desconvidar o eleitor brasileiro de participar da maior festa democrática do Brasil.
Candidato, por que voltar a atacar a credibilidade das urnas eletrônicas, como fez o seu pai?
É até importante, até para eu conscientizar quem está nos ouvindo, porque a minha fala foi falando sobre o assunto que estava acontecendo no momento, fora do Brasil.
E eu sou bem claro, eu falo assim, não estou questionando as urnas eletrônicas.
E realmente, de fato, eu disse lá que a empresa que fazia, que fez as urnas eletrônicas, ou parte delas no Brasil, era uma empresa venezuelana.
Falei errado, ela não fabricou as urnas, ela apenas participou de alguns processos ao longo ali do processo eleitoral que o TSE estava organizando.
Então, tirando essa parte que, de fato, eu falei equivocadamente, eu fui bem claro a dizer que jamais questionei a questão do processo eleitoral.
Quero dizer a todos vocês que vou respeitar o processo eleitoral, vou respeitar o resultado das eleições.
Eu estou concorrendo com essas regras, eu vou ser presidente da República com essas regras.
Se Deus quiser, a Renata, que está aqui, vai anunciar no dia 4 de outubro que Flávio Bolsonaro é o novo presidente do Brasil, eleito em 2026.
Eu quero convocar todos vocês que saiam de casa para votar.
Foram mais de 32 milhões de pessoas que não foram votar nas eleições de 2022.
E ela foi decidida por algo em torno de 2 milhões de votos.
Então, é muito importante que você participe se você também quer uma mudança do seu país.
Estão proclamados o resultado pelo TSE, o senhor diz que vai respeitar o resultado das urnas, mesmo se perder.
Com certeza, eu vou adorar que você anuncie o meu nome como presidente daquela bancada internacional.
Mesmo se perder, candidato?
Eu não vou perder essa eleição. E eu digo mais, eu vou ganhar no primeiro turno.
Candidato, tarifaço. O presidente Trump impôs um tarifaço de 50% contra o Brasil.
No dia desse anúncio, 9 de julho do ano passado, seu irmão Eduardo Bolsonaro foi às redes sociais comemorar.
Pediu que os brasileiros agradecessem a Trump.
Ele fez questão também de dizer que atuou nos Estados Unidos para obter medidas contra autoridades brasileiras
com o objetivo de interferir no processo criminal do seu pai, Jair Bolsonaro.
Então, eu pergunto ao senhor, por que, nesse episódio, ele colocou os interesses da família Bolsonaro à frente dos interesses do Brasil?
Olha, se o Eduardo tivesse colocado os seus próprios interesses na frente do Brasil, ele não teria ficado exilado como está nos Estados Unidos hoje.
Ele faz um trabalho lá de conscientização, de mostrar ao mundo o que está acontecendo no Brasil hoje,
que está longe de ser uma democracia plena.
Ele nunca pediu tarifas para empresas brasileiras.
Inclusive, eu, Tralho, fiz questão de também, no mesmo dia, vir a público e dizer que era contrário a isso,
que não defendia, que ia defender os interesses das empresas brasileiras,
e ia trabalhar para a retirada dessas tarifas junto ao governo americano, como eu fiz.
Eu fui, no momento adequado, Tralho, até a USTR, que é a Câmara de Comércio Internacional dos Estados Unidos,
para defender o Brasil, para que o governo americano não tarifasse mais as empresas brasileiras,
que já são as mais tarifadas do mundo pelo próprio governo Lula.
As empresas brasileiras não conseguem mais, não têm capacidade mais de pagar mais impostos,
e mais essa sobretase que foi o Lula que cavou com força.
E o Lula procurou muito essa tarifa.
Ele xingou, ele ameaçou, ele conseguiu.
Parabéns, Lula, você conseguiu tarifar as empresas brasileiras.
Candidato, no dia 9 de julho de 2025, mesmo dia em que o Trump anunciou o tarifaço,
o seu irmão, Eduardo Bolsonaro, vai à rede social X e diz o seguinte,
povo brasileiro, vamos fazer o mundo ouvir a nossa voz.
Coloque o seu agradecimento ao presidente Donald Trump abaixo
e vamos rumo à lei Magnitsky.
Obrigado, presidente Trump.
Por conta disso, no dia 16 de junho desse ano,
seu irmão foi condenado a quatro anos e dois meses de prisão
por coação no processo da trama golpista.
A primeira turma do Supremo entendeu que ele tentou interferir no julgamento do pai.
O senhor acha correto misturar interesse pessoal com interesse eleitoral e interesse nacional?
Eu não acho correto como eu não acho correto com a Alexandre de Moraes,
uma parte interessada nesse processo, condena Eduardo.
Já que ele era o alvo da lei Magnitsky, conforme as leis e decisões do governo americano,
agora você não pode acusar o Eduardo de manipular o Trump.
Já seria demais.
O Trump faz o que está na cabeça dele.
Essa política de tarifa...
Mas por que o Eduardo elogiou o Trump no Twitter, então?
Olha, ele assumiu que ele estava trabalhando para defender as liberdades do povo brasileiro
e denunciar aquele que é um violador de direitos humanos internacionais, que é o Alexandre de Moraes.
Mas o dia seguinte é o tarifácio? Ele agradece?
Eu acho que ele errou de agradecer com relação às tarifas.
O trabalho que ele fez lá para conscientizar, e a decisão que ele tomou foi o governo americano,
não foi o Eduardo Bolsonaro, portanto ele não tem absolutamente nada a ver com isso.
O governo podia ignorar o que ele está falando.
O governo tem as informações, tem os serviços de inteligência, enfim.
Mas o senhor tentou, por exemplo, acionar o governo americano.
O senhor pediu que o governo Trump adiasse o tarifácio.
Ou seja, por que o senhor não cobrou do governo Trump para suspender quando o senhor teve oportunidade de fazer?
Está cobrado lá.
Que desistisse.
Não, não. Está cobrado lá que eu fui contra as tarifas.
Mas o único representante público, o único agente público brasileiro que foi para os Estados Unidos defender o Brasil
foi Flávio Bolsonaro.
O governo Lula não mandou umzinho para fazer a defesa no momento adequado.
Mas por que adiar e não suspender?
Eu pedi para cancelar as tarifas e, assessoramente, eu falei o seguinte, olha só, presidente Trump.
Parece, em outras palavras, tá, Renato?
Parece que o Lula está provocando essa tarifa, ele está atacando os Estados Unidos,
ele ataca o secretário de Estado, Marco Rubio.
Está fazendo de tudo para que as tarifas sejam aplicadas ao Brasil,
para, com isso, ele acreditar que está tendo algum benefício eleitoral com isso.
Vamos ter eleições em breve e, se Deus quiser, Flávio Bolsonaro vai ser o novo presidente do Brasil
e vai ter a capacidade de sentar de igual para igual com o Trump e negociar na mesa, Renato,
sem tarifas, sem imposição de sanções às empresas brasileiras.
Eu tenho certeza que eu vou ter condições de fazer isso.
Mas, candidato, só para esclarecer o que o senhor disse na carta, no despacho que o senhor fez para o governo americano,
não se pede ao representante de comércio que se encerre a investigação.
Pede-se adiar a implementação da medida já determinada.
A investigação já estava concluída naquele momento, para começar, Renato.
E, mais uma vez, a gente tem que entender ou tentar entender como é que funciona a cabeça de quem está do lado de lá.
Se é que se na cabeça dele a possibilidade de uma troca de governo, já que ele está fazendo,
ele parece em represália a atitude do presidente do Brasil de atacar o governo americano.
Se tem a possibilidade de ele ser sensível a uma troca de governo que pode acontecer em breve
e ele não tarifar as empresas brasileiras, foi apenas mais um dos argumentos acessórios
que eu tinha naquele momento e eu tentei usar para defender o Brasil.
E o PIX, candidato?
O PIX é um dos motivos...
Com a ação com os Estados Unidos?
De forma alguma, Tralho.
O PIX é sagrado, o PIX é do brasileiro.
Foi feito na gestão do presidente Bolsonaro.
Não tem taxa no PIX porque o Bolsonaro exigiu que não tivesse...
Seu irmão errou em tão oferente.
Não tem...
Seu irmão e as pessoas terem tentado tarifar o PIX.
O Eduardo, o que ele falou fez...
Na verdade, isso aí foi uma distorção do que ele falou, Tralho, porque ele só disse
o seguinte, olha, aqui nos Estados Unidos também tem uma ferramenta parecida.
Por que que é o PIX?
É um meio de pagamento.
É igual a tinha um TED.
É um PIX que foi ali criado no governo do presidente Bolsonaro e que não tem nem como
sancionar o PIX, Sotralho.
Mas por que, então, naquele momento, candidato, ele não foi mais enfático e disse claramente
o PIX é inegociável?
Não, eu estou sendo aqui, o PIX é inegociável e ele não quis dizer isso, que o PIX estava
em negociação.
Candidato, vamos falar agora aqui de assunto importante relacionado à segurança pública.
As investigações sobre assuntos que interessam segurança pública mostram, olha só, relação
em relação sua com Adriano da Nóbrega.
Adriano da Nóbrega, que liderou o Escritório do Crime no Rio de Janeiro.
Então, eu pergunto ao senhor...
Nesse momento, ele, até a gente lembra aqui, Trale, que o senhor concedeu uma medalha, o
senhor concedeu uma medalha, tira dentes ao Adriano da Nóbrega.
Ele estava preso por homicídio, era um dos maiores assassinos de aluguel do Brasil
e foi morto numa operação policial na Bahia.
Por que homenagear um dos maiores matadores do Rio de Janeiro?
Importante demais a sua pergunta, para que todo mundo que está nos assistindo aqui compreenda
o momento em que isso aconteceu.
Essa homenagem, Trale e Renata, foi feita há mais de 20 anos, se não me engano.
No momento em que ele era um policial reconhecido.
Eu conheci ele dentro do BOPE, o batalhão de elite da Polícia Militar do Rio de Janeiro.
Não tinha feito absolutamente nada de errado, não tinha nada contra ele nesta época.
E quando ele estava preso, acusado de homicídio, é porque na época tinha uma política dizendo
o seguinte, olha, primeiro a gente pune o policial e depois ele explica se ele é inocente ou não.
E eu, como sempre tive uma atuação de defesa dos policiais, dos bons policiais, e sempre terei,
ele estava sendo falsamente acusado de ter cometido homicídio e, na verdade, foi uma troca de tiros com o traficante.
Depois ficou comprovado que ele tinha trocado tiros com este traficante e ele foi absolvido.
E um gesto em homenagem não a ele, mas a toda guarnição que estava sendo injustamente condenada
por ter trocado tiros com vagabundos e matado um marginal, foi uma forma simbólica que eu aprendi,
que eu entendi que podia naquele momento acontecer.
Ele era suspeito de participar do assassinato de mais de tens pessoas.
Foi morto, inclusive, num confronto com a polícia, na Bahia.
Nessa época era uma homenagem de não.
Isso foi bem depois, eu não posso ser responsabilizado pelo que a pessoa se transforma depois de 5, 10, 15, 20 anos.
Vamos combinar que não está no meu controle isso.
Mas as investigações, por exemplo, sobre a rachadinha no seu gabinete,
mostraram que a esposa e a mãe desse Adriano, que chefiou o escritório do crime no Rio de Janeiro,
o senhor empregou elas na Alerje.
Elas chegaram a ser acusadas de praticar a chamada rachadinha, as provas foram anuladas pela justiça,
mas o caso revelou a proximidade do senhor com a família dele.
Volto a perguntar, por que empregar a família de um chefe de um grupo de matadores?
Renato, mais uma vez, na época ele não era isso.
Na época ele era um policial exemplar que estava sendo preso, estava preso injustamente.
Foi quando eu conheci os familiares dele, a mãe principalmente, que participava de movimentos de defesa,
de esposas e mulheres de militares, de policiais perseguidos injustamente.
Então ela liderava o movimento, como sempre foi minha bandeira, a defesa dos policiais, dos bons policiais.
Eu achei por mim que trazia ela para trabalhar comigo e ela fazia essa...
Eu vou te responder.
E ela fazia essa intermediação das demandas das famílias de policiais militares com o meu gabinete.
Ele trabalhava direitinho, sem problema nenhum.
Só que, mais uma vez, uma pessoa que estava presa injustamente, ele foi absolvido depois dessa acusação pela qual ele estava preso, Renato.
Então as pessoas têm direito de expor do processo legal.
O policial militar também é ser humano, não pode ser um servidor de segunda categoria,
como qualquer ser humano, qualquer cidadão brasileiro, diferente dos militares daquela época.
A acusação tem que provar que alguém cometeu algum crime.
E nessa época, ele estava preso quando teve a possibilidade de mostrar que ele era inocente.
Assim que foi feito, assim que foi reconhecido pela justiça.
Inclusive o senhor concedeu uma medalha a ele nesse momento.
Quando ele era perseguido, inocente e não tinha absolutamente nenhuma dessas acusações.
Candidato, o senhor também chegou a apoiar a candidatura do Rodrigo Bacelar para o governo do Estado.
Ele foi presidente da Assembleia do Rio, ele está preso.
E a Polícia Federal disse que ele exercia a liderança política do núcleo do Comando Vermelho.
Não é grave, candidato?
É muito grave, se eu soubesse disso, jamais.
Se forem comprovadas as acusações contra ele, já que ele também está respondendo ao processo,
se forem comprovadas, é gravíssimo.
Mas isso ali era uma...
Na verdade, o nome dele surgiu numa composição partidária no Rio de Janeiro,
em que ele estava sendo ali indicado por um partido que estava na nossa coalizão.
E aí ele tem direito de se defender e de provar a inocência dele ou não na justiça.
Nós vamos agora fazer um rápido intervalo, né, Renata?
A gente volta já já entrevistando Flávio Bolsonaro, o candidato do PL à presidência da República.
A gente volta já.
Estamos de volta com a entrevista com o candidato Flávio Bolsonaro.
Candidato, vamos falar aqui de economia, dívida pública.
O programa de governo do senhor promete estabilizar e reduzir a dívida pública do Brasil,
que está em trajetória de alta.
Mas não traz números, também não traz prazos.
O plano diz que isso ocorreria no menor prazo possível.
De quanto seria exatamente o seu ajuste fiscal em reais ou em pontos do PIB?
E de onde é que sairia esse dinheiro?
Trale, a gente tem que entender que se o Brasil não tiver um ajuste fiscal forte,
está fadado aí a falência de todo mundo.
Então, a quebradeira generalizada, você que está me acompanhando provavelmente está endividado
ou conhece alguém que está endividado, mas a culpa não é sua, a culpa é desse atual governo.
Quando é um governo que gasta demais, aumenta os impostos de forma alucinada,
mais de 30 impostos criados ou aumentados só nesse atual governo,
pra arrecadar mais e continua gastando mais ainda a taxa de juros oficial,
que é a Selic, vai lá pra lua.
14% é o maior juro real do mundo.
E sabe, Trale, quanto é que era a previsão?
Lá em outubro de 2022, a previsão do mercado era que, neste momento,
a taxa de juros no Brasil, se fosse o governo do presidente Bolsonaro,
ia estar em torno de 7%, metade.
Se nós estamos falando de uns juros, de pagamento de juros na hora,
é de um trilhão de reais ao ano.
E a taxa de juros era pra estar metade, Trale.
A gente está falando de 500 bilhões de reais.
Para que patamar da dívida pública brasileira o senhor se compromete a trazer?
Vou chegar lá.
Meio trilhão de reais por ano que você, pagador de impostos,
está sustentando esse governo, a gastança desse governo.
Ou seja, só aqui tem dois trilhões de reais que se fosse um governo que cortasse na carne,
um governo que economizasse, que cortasse despesas,
certamente a sua dívida não estaria nesse nível.
Porque quanto sobe a taxa de juros, a taxa de juros do seu financiamento,
do seu endividamento, cresce junto, a parcela da sua dívida aumenta também.
Então, se você deve 200 reais, você podia estar levando 180,
podia estar levando 150, 140, se tivesse um governo como vai ser.
Você dá até a sua oportunidade de mostrar a sua proposta do que o senhor vai fazer.
Sim, eu estou explicando aqui.
Por exemplo, o que o senhor vai fazer.
Sobre o salário mínimo, por exemplo, que é muito importante.
Há uma divergência de propostas entre as propostas feitas pelos seus colaboradores
e o que está no seu programa de governo.
O coordenador da sua campanha critica a política atual de reajuste do salário mínimo
e das aposentadorias e benefícios.
O seu plano não trata desse assunto.
Eu preciso saber qual é a sua decisão.
O salário mínimo teria um aumento real ou não, se o senhor foi eleito?
Renata, eu não vou fazer economia do povo mais sofrido brasileiro.
Quem recebe salário mínimo hoje está perdendo o seu poder de compra por causa da gastança do governo.
Não vou fazer economia em cima de você.
Eu vou fazer um governo enxuta.
Eu vou reduzir a quantidade de ministérios.
Eu vou cortar a burocracia.
Eu vou fazer tesouraço nos impostos.
Vou cortar mais de mil atos normativos já no início do meu governo,
por decreto, aquilo que eu puder fazer.
A nossa equipe econômica aqui tem mais de 10 economistas pegadinha trabalhando já nisso.
É assim que a gente vai começar a reduzir o custo do Brasil.
Hoje o Lula aumentou a dívida primária do Brasil em mais de 330 bilhões de reais, Renata.
É uma gastança sem precedentes na história desse Brasil.
Para que patamar o senhor pretende trazê-la?
Eu vou cortar ministérios.
Eu vou fazer um tesouraço, inclusive, nos cargos comissionados.
O presidente Bolsonaro, em 2019, cortou 20 mil cargos em comissão.
Agora o atual governo já criou mais 22 mil.
Eu vou fazer um combate à corrupção firme nesse governo.
Aposentadorias, candidato, e benefícios vão continuar sendo reajustados com o salário mínimo?
Tralho, eu vou chegar lá e vou te explicar por que não precisa também fazer economia em cima dos aposentados.
Porque nós vamos fazer um governo que vai combater a corrupção,
como foi a MP 871 do governo do presidente Bolsonaro,
que tinha um pacote antifraude, anticorrupção no INSS,
que o PT trabalhou para derrubar essas medidas que combateriam a corrupção
e que evitariam que os aposentados do INSS tivinhassem sido roubados, como foram roubados,
nesse atual governo.
Vou combater a roubalheira que hoje está generalizada nesse atual governo.
Vou criar uma governança tecnológica, Renato, dentro do meu governo.
Vai ter um data center soberano para o Brasil, como já tem em Singapura, como tem na Coreia do Sul,
que vai controlar cada centavo de gasto público.
Eu vou começar economizando dinheiro daí.
E com o ajuste fiscal, que nós faremos resgatando a credibilidade desse país,
que é uma coisa que influencia na taxa de juros, Renato,
porque esse governo, ninguém mais acredita que ele faça ajuste fiscal,
porque ele gasta fora do orçamento e não está nem aí.
Mas então, sobre o reajuste do salário mínimo,
o senhor desautoriza o seu coordenador de campanha que critica a atual política de reajuste.
Não farei economia com quem ganha salário mínimo, não farei economia com aposentados.
Eu vou fazer economia cortando corrupção, fazendo tesouraço na burocracia,
reduzindo os impostos.
Só com o anúncio da eleição de Flávio Bolsonaro como presidente da República
e com a equipe que vai ter essa cara que todos estão vendo,
com a equipe de técnicos, de economistas, de pessoas sérias,
de pessoas que são competentes, que estão ali por um projeto de Brasil,
a taxa de juros já vai cair na reunião seguinte do Copom, do Banco Central,
e cada 1% de taxa de juros a menos que nós pagamos é cerca de R$ 90 bilhões que abre dentro do orçamento.
Então, quero ouvir o senhor, candidato.
É o primeiro recurso que eu vou conseguir fazer, tratar quem precisa nesse Brasil,
abraçar quem precisa nesse Brasil e estender a mão para que você evolua.
Pois não.
Quero ouvir o senhor sobre o tema importante, é meio ambiente.
Num artigo publicado em 2019, o senhor afirmou que não existe aquecimento global.
Disse que isso é um discurso apocalíptico para barrar o progresso.
E o senhor declarou que o mundo, na verdade, estaria passando por um resfriamento.
Candidato, os cientistas dizem o contrário, o oposto.
O senhor mantém a sua opinião mesmo diante de todas as mais recentes evidências climáticas?
Olha, Renato, é importante você fazer essa colocação,
que eu consigo recolocar o que eu falei sobre isso.
Porque, para mim, o que acontece hoje é que são eventos climáticos que são extremos.
Excesso de calor, excesso de chuva, excesso de seca.
Então, eu acredito que são efeitos cíclicos.
E a maior forma de a gente trabalhar o meio ambiente foi o que nós fizemos no governo do presidente Bolsonaro.
Aprovar o marco legal do saneamento básico para combater o esgoto que passa na porta da sua casa que está me assistindo.
E a prefeitura ou o governo do estado não tem capacidade de investimento para te dar um esgoto tratado,
para levar água filtrada para a sua torneira.
É assim que a gente vai combater os lixões.
É com esses programas que vão principalmente dentro de áreas urbanas.
Com relação às grandes áreas como a Amazônia, muitas vezes, Renato, o problema é até mais criminal do que ambiental.
Acabamos de ver o Comando Vermelho agora também está explorando ouro em reserva indígena.
Então, é um problema que vai ser combatido no meu governo.
Mas deixa eu só entender, então, o senhor acha que não tem aquecimento global?
Não existe?
Eu acho que tem eventos climáticos extremos.
Tem épocas cíclicas que fazem mais calor, tem épocas que fazem mais frio, tem épocas que chovem mais.
E eu não acho que isso tem a ver diretamente só com a influência do ser humano no ambiente.
Isso não é negar as evidências científicas, candidato?
Não, eu estou falando que eu concordo que existem eventos climáticos.
Agora, deixa eu só aproveitar a sua...
Por que o senhor não colocou no plano de governo como mitigar os efeitos do clima?
Ou seja, que ações que o senhor vai tomar em relação a isso para proteger as populações das mudanças climáticas?
O Trale, a melhor forma que nós temos de proteger o meio ambiente é oferecer um saneamento básico para a população.
Isso impacta, inclusive, na saúde.
Eu quero falar para você hoje, que tem dificuldade de achar um médico numa UBS,
você que não tem, na hora de pegar o seu filho e levar com febre, passando mal,
para a humanidade de saúde perto da sua casa, você não encontra remédio.
Eu quero falar para você que eu vou enfrentar essa situação como prioridade no meu governo.
Eu vou transformar a saúde pública numa saúde de qualidade.
O SUS vai ser moderno.
E eu quero aproveitar, Renato, para fazer um anúncio aqui em homenagem a você,
Trale em homenagem a você, Renata, que conversei com uma pessoa muito importante,
uma pessoa que trabalhou por muito tempo na iniciativa privada,
alguém que está ali pronto para dar a sua contribuição na parte da saúde.
E eu quero dizer que conversei com o doutor Cláudio Lothenberg,
que vai ser o meu ministro da saúde, uma pessoa preparada,
que vai poder adotar as melhores práticas do setor privado para o SUS.
O senhor está nas suas considerações finais, candidato.
Então, o nosso tempo está esgotado.
As suas considerações finais, por favor,
o senhor pode continuar a falar sobre isso, mas o senhor tem um minuto.
Então, eu quero agradecer ao doutor Cláudio Lothenberg por aceitar esse convite
para ser o meu ministro da saúde.
Eu acho que é uma pasta importante que a população leva muito em consideração.
Quem precisa do SUS tem contra muita dificuldade.
Eu quero agradecer ao senhor e à senhora que ficaram até esse momento assistindo
as minhas falas.
Eu queria ter falado mais de proposta, mais de futuro,
mas não vai faltar oportunidade para que façamos isso.
E eu quero te fazer chamar uma reflexão.
O que a sua vida melhorou nos últimos quatro anos?
Você acha que você que está devendo vai dever mais ou vai dever menos
se continuar o atual governo?
Você que está sofrendo com a violência, que mora numa área dominada
por narcoterroristas,
daqui a quatro anos, se continuar o atual governo,
você vai estar vivendo com mais ou com menos violência?
Você que está vendo os escândalos de corrupção nesse governo,
você consegue, você acha que daqui a quatro anos vai viver com mais ou menos corrupção?
Então, eu quero pedir uma oportunidade.
Você pode não concordar com muita coisa que eu falo,
você pode ter alguma desconfiança com relação ao que eu vou fazer no meu governo,
mas do lado de lá você sabe, tem 100% de certeza que vai dar errado.
Então, eu quero pedir a você, se você também quer uma mudança,
não precisa gostar de Flávio Bolsonaro.
Goste de você.
Muito obrigado.
Flávio Bolsonaro, presidente 22.
Candidato, obrigada pela entrevista.
Muito agradeço.
Muito obrigado, candidato, pela presença do senhor aqui.
Amanhã, o nosso entrevistado é o candidato Augusto Cury do Avante.
Boa noite.
Boa noite para você e até amanhã.